-I think most people thought
I peaked in my second year
in the league,
and I didn't peak at 21.
-Alley-oop for Brown.
And it goes coast to coast.
-Once again, Brown.
-During the draft process,
an exec said
that you were too smart.
-That was true.
-To Brown.
-Knocks down a three!
-Was your role last year, and
what was your role this year,
and what do you attribute
that leap to?
-Space. I think we had
a lot of guys last year.
I think that wasn't a secret.
I was asked
to come off the bench.
♪♪
-My name is Jaylen Brown --
Cal Bear, Boston Celtic,
Georgia boy, Atlanta native,
and she about to be all up
in my business,
but we're going to take it there
with Taylor Rooks.
-Jaylen Brown.
That's a throw.
Jaylen Brown knocks down
a huge shot.
-What is this? What is this?
-Acne Studio.
Just came in today.
-This is fine.
This is my vibe right here.
-This is it,
with jeans and pants?
We got some sweatpants.
-You know me.
-Yes, sir.
-Okay, so how are you
as a client?
Like, you know what you like.
Is it easy for you?
-Yeah, we've been
working together for --
-A year-plus.
-She picks the clothes,
and then I'll put it together.
-All right, now, Jaylen,
I've always wondered this,
like, as I look
at these clothes.
Now, be honest.
How do you decide
what you're going to wear
for, like, a regional game
or a national game,
and is there a thought
process behind it?
For me, it depends.
Like, how I dress
is just basically,
like, how I'm feeling
at the time.
Like, I try to, like, mood it,
like,
how I'm going to be feeling,
like, if we're playing
a certain team,
Like, I'll have a fit
already put together,
but I'll only wear it
when I feel
I'm feeling that fit.
Does that make sense?
-No, I feel you,
'cause, see, in my head,
I thought it was like, "All
right, listen, we're playing
the -- I don't know,
we're playing the Lakers.
I got to get the fit up.
I got to get the pic
in the tunnel."
You don't ever think
that at all.
-I mean, everybody does.
I want to win the game first.
-Absolutely.
-That's a topic of discussion
right now.
-Oh yes. Who was it?
J.J. Redick was talking about --
-J.J. Redick said that.
So I'm all about winning first.
But for me, always being seen,
got to look good.
So she helps me look good.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-She don't got to do much.
-Ah, here we go.
Yes, you do.
I know how you dress him.
-[ Chuckles ]
-You know, it's interesting,
'cause last year,
when they announced
the extension,
a lot of people,
they're, like --
Twitter, almost felt like it
was too much,
they shouldn't have paid you.
How did that feel
knowing that there was
this kind of negative reaction
to the extension?
-I kind of anticipated it.
I kind of felt like that was
what's going to be said.
I think most people
thought I peaked
in my second year in the league,
and I didn't peak at 21.
I'm only going to get
better from here.
Certain people think that
I'm playing out of my mind now
'cause they didn't expect it.
You know, so that's part
of the reason why I cut my hair,
'cause people will put you in
a box per certain stipulations
or try to identify you
a certain way,
and I wanted people to kind of
see me different this year.
-I think a lot of people
wouldn't know how to bounce back
from maybe
what was a tough year.
Mentally, how did you
become better after that?
-It was tough.
I suffer from a lot of anxiety.
When you have
some of these expectations,
especially in a city
like Boston,
which is, like,
they want to win,
if they're not performing,
you start to lose
your confidence,
you start to doubt yourself.
A part of me
coming into this year
was, like, not dealing with
that negativity,
like, saying,
"'F' that. Fuck that."
I said,
"Cut my hair, cut my care."
Like, "Let him go,
stop caring what people think,"
and I reached a new pinnacle
of happiness and peace.
Yes.
-Okay. He's feeling himself.
Please take off the jacket.
-No, I love it.
-Please take it off.
I see you, like,
attempting some waves.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-Little bit.
It's a little swimmy.
-Yo, she just tried
to play me like that.
-He's waving a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a process.
You know what I mean?
Get the close-up.
Hold up, man. Get the close-up.
You know what I mean?
Waves coming in.
360. All right back up.
That's it.
-Yeah, see, you can't see it
when you're close.
-She got jokes today, okay.
I'm letting you rock.
I ain't say nothing
about your ankles.
Look. Zoom in.
-Ah!
They ashy?
-They look -- look,
don't try to hide.
-No, you can zoom in
at my ankles. Zoom in.
It's fair. It's fair game.
Do you have any lotion for me?
-Nope.
-No you don't. Okay.
Can we see your ankles?
-Nope. Next fit.
-I saw a story when you were
playing the Jazz last season,
and, in game,
Donovan Mitchell came up
and said something to you.
-Mm-hmm.
-Can you tell me that story?
-That was one of the games
that kind of stood out
because I was at the brink.
I felt like things
were out of my control.
I felt like, you know,
I have this amount of talent,
and I was asked
to take a back seat.
It was very hard
for me to deal with.
In the middle of the game,
like, Donovan comes up to me,
like, asked me, like,
"Bro, you good?"
You know, most people tell you,
if I were to ask you,
"Were you good?"
you would tell me you were good
even though you might not be.
Right? So I told him
I was good, and I really wasn't.
People asked me, like Danny
Ainge asked me if I was okay.
Told him I was good.
But in reality, I had, like,
a lot of anxiety, you know,
dealing with, you know,
that whole scenario last year.
It was a lot for me. It took
a lot to get out of that.
-I called Donovan and asked
about that moment, and he said,
you know, "I have known Jaylen
a long time.
I know how he is.
So I knew something was wrong."
-For me, I like
to isolate myself sometimes.
So not being around people
was kind of, like, the way
I kind of deal with things,
and it's not always the best way
to kind of deal with stuff.
Family and friends
are necessary.
Talking about it to people
or having somebody to vent to
or having somebody help lift
you up can be good.
-You said something that I
thought was interesting
in that same story
that you're as good
as the role that you're in.
What was your role last year,
and what was your role
this year,
and what do you attribute
that leap to?
-Space. I think we had a lot
of guys last year.
I think that wasn't a secret.
Last year, I was asked
to come off the bench
after coming off
of a great playoffs,
a great second year.
This year, I'm one of the
starters, one of the leaders,
so I have a lot
more responsibility,
a lot more weight to carry.
People had the expectations
of me what I'm doing now,
but I didn't have
that responsibility.
It's a blessing. I don't look
at it as a negative thing.
I look at it as a great thing.
I learned so much more
about myself.
So I'm not knocking the Celtics.
It was actually needed for me
to go to where I'm trying to go.
-Jaylen Brown!
-Got both of you something.
[ Laughter ]
-My dawg.
-Got me some lotion.
You know what?
Good looking, though.
Good looking on the ankles.
-Thank you, A.K.
-No problem.
-[ Laughs ]
-So, what is it like having
Kemba Walker on the team now?
-Kemba is like somebody, like,
you knew growing up
all your life,
just, like, the homey,
the older brother
that's been through it all,
seen it all,
and just happy to be here.
-What's he like as a leader?
When I saw Kemba's leadership
for the first time was at USA.
Obviously the goal
that we had didn't plan out
the way we expected it to.
We all wanted to win.
We didn't want to come home
unless we did win, and we lost.
Kemba, the way he handled that
and lifted everybody up
and told us,
"This is not the end.
Everybody's going to be better
from this," was great for us.
-Speaking of Team USA,
Jayson Tatum.
-Mm-hmm.
-First off,
how often do people say "Jayson"
when they mean "Jaylen"
and "Jaylen"
when they mean "Jayson"
'cause I always almost do it?
-Brad does it a lot.
Brad be drawing up the play
and be saying Jaylen,
but put "J.T." on the clipboard.
So me and J.T.
look at each other.
We're like, "All right, bro.
One of us is going
to get the bucket."
Like, It don't even matter.
-What is it about Jayson Tatum
that makes him so good?
That "it" factor,
that niceness factor.
He can do the same move
as somebody else.
It just look better
when he do it.
You know what I mean?
He just got it.
Some people got it
and some people don't.
He got that "it" factor,
for sure.
-Black tee inside
with black jeans?
What would you like?
-I'll try the jacket on
right now.
Growing up in Atlanta,
where I'm from,
people will talk about you.
It's a part of the culture.
You come to school,
and your shoes is busted up,
people will, like,
make fun of you.
You know, so growing up
in that culture,
what you have on your feet
was always, like,
the most important thing.
To this day, like,
I look at people's shoes
before I look at their face.
I don't know why that is.
Just growing up, like, it's just
been conditioned that way.
-Who in the NBA style
do you like,
like, you feel like
they are very well-dressed?
-P.J. Tucker. I feel like
he's the best-dressed dude
in the league for sure.
Tyson Chandler is the O.G.
If I was 40 years old
and I was 7 foot,
I would dress like him.
He got nice style, too.
-You good?
We got everything you need?
-Got everything.
-All right, we out?
-We out.
-Perfect.
Thank you, A.K.
Okay, Jaylen,
time to take you home.
-Okay, true or false and why
is the game, okay?
You have to pick one.
Don't go between the two.
You got to pick true or false.
-I got you.
-Okay. "Queen & Slim" is better
than "Love & Basketball."
-Whoa.
I'm going to go false.
I love "Queen & Slim,"
but off of G.P.,
general principle,
I'm going to have to go
"Love & Basketball."
It's a classic.
-True or false and why --
during the draft process,
an exec said
that you were too smart.
-That was true. I don't know
why the exec thought
that that would be a bad thing.
I think when, you know,
athletes are also informative,
it might intimidate people
for whatever reason.
LeBron and K.D. with the whole
"Shut Up and Dribble" movement
was a big push
in the generation
because athletes get
a pushback from society
for, you know,
their outside interests,
and I feel like this generation
that I'm a part of now,
I think
it's a movement going on,
and I'm a part
of that movement.
-Okay. True or false and why --
I tricked you into saying
you're going to get five rings.
-True. Very true.
-I do want to give you
the opportunity to explain,
'cause I know you feel like
it was taken out of context.
-How many championships
28-year-old Jaylen got?
-I'm not going to jinx myself,
but six years,
I'm going to go ahead
and say five or six.
I'm going to say that.
-So you winning a championship
every year from here to --
-Yeah, I don't want
to jinx myself.
-You already did.
You already said it.
-And I don't play to lose.
So I'm going to go ahead
and say --
I'm going to give it a five.
-I didn't set you up.
I just asked you a question.
-Right. I didn't say
you set me up.
-Okay.
-But the way, you know, they
kind of, like, put it out there,
the clickbait title was
"Jaylen Brown said
he's going to have..."
When people look at that,
like, "Who does Jaylen Brown
think he is to say he's going to
have five or six rings
by the time he's 28?"
You know, I had to answer to,
like, Danny Ainge.
Like, he came to me
and was like,
"You're being disrespectful,"
but I didn't mean
any disrespect,
'cause I know how hard it is
just to win one.
I wasn't guaranteeing anything,
I wasn't trying to be arrogant,
or I wasn't saying
that this is going to happen.
I was just like, if I wanted
things to go a certain way,
that's the way
I want them to go.
I'm over it.
I'm past it.
I'm glad you brought it up,
'cause we low-key had beef.
-We absolutely had beef.
We absolutely had beef.
We Gucci now, though.
I was like,
"Don't leave me hanging there.
We Gucci."
Take me to your decision
to go to Cal.
-I was number one, number two,
number three
high school recruit,
so I could've went to pretty
much any school I wanted to.
Kentucky, Kansas,
North Carolina,
UCLA --
all great schools.
It just wasn't fit for me.
I was actually sitting next
to a girl in AP World History,
and I was listening to her
narrowing down her list,
and the reasons why she
was narrowing down her list
was totally different from mine.
I was looking at jersey colors.
She was looking at, like,
the business climate
outside of, like, this.
She was looking at all --
I asked her to help me
narrow down my list.
She looked at some school,
and she was like,
"No, no, no," and she was like,
"This is a good school,"
and one of those schools
was Cal.
-What was her name?
-Michelle.
-Shout out to Michelle.
Speaking of that process,
'cause I heard
a little rumor once,
how close were you
to going to North Carolina?
-I was very close
to going to UNC.
To this day, I love,
absolutely adore Coach Roy,
'cause UNC growing up,
my mom would tell you,
like, I was the biggest UNC fan.
I had all the memorabilia.
I had everything, like, M.J.,
everything, and Roy came.
When he came on a visit, he
brought, like, Jordan's rings.
-Oh, he pulled out
all the stops.
-He did the whole thing.
So it was hard for me not to go.
My mom, she made me
do something interesting.
When I committed, she made me
call every head coach
from the schools
that I wasn't going to
and tell them why
I wasn't going.
She was like,
"You're going to have to
conduct business one day,
and you need to learn how
to manage these relationships,"
and Roy was one of the very few,
like, one of two, I think,
that I talked to him
for about an hour,
and he talked to me about, like,
what he saw in my potential,
what he compared it to.
That made me, like,
look at him different.
-Absolutely,
'cause genuinely cared.
-Yeah, so that stuck with me.
Even though I didn't go to UNC
and everything turned out
the way it was supposed to,
I always look back over
my shoulder, like, "What if?"
We played in preseason
against Charlotte
two years ago at Chapel Hill.
I went and gave him a big hug,
and I almost, like,
dropped a tear.
To this day, if, Roy, you need
some help with anything,
recruitment, I got you, bro.
-He got you.
Got some good clothes?
Get your pic off.
[ Laughs ]
-Here you go.
-Post on the 'Gram.
You trying to post on the 'Gram?
-You trying to be funny.
-[ Laughs ] I am funny.
Well, thank you for letting us
spend a day with you.
I took a lot of time
but worth it.
-No problem. Appreciate you.
My pleasure.
Thanks so much, Jaylen.
Have a good season.
-All right. I'm out.
♪♪